-Now, you can do your poker face
when you're looking at this.
The acting starts now.
-Oh, it's a toaster oven.
[ Laughing ] Oh, yeah.
-Okay.
-Alright.
-So...
inside my box...
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, cool.
That's interesting.
-Okay, so the audience
has now seen it.
Oh.
[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Humming ]
So let's see.
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
Oh.
Whoa.
[ Laughter ]
It's an everyday thing.
Here you go. This is where
you make your choice, yeah.
[ Clears throat ]
-It's a, um...
It's an interesting thing.
[ Laughter ]
So, um...
-What?
"It's an interesting thing."
In my box...
is what I assume to be...
shavings of a pickle...
in the shape of a welcome mat,
a tiny welcome mat
for possibly a dollhouse.
-What is in my box is...
a bowl of chili
frozen in gelatin.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm very familiar with this.
-Okay.
-It's ice cream in a...
looks like a Houston Astros hat,
a baseball --
upside-down baseball hat.
[ Laughs ]
Why are you laughing?
Pumpkin with "pisghetti" on it.
-Spaghetti.
-Yeah, I wanted to see
if you were acting.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Laughs ]
-It is, um...
a Rubik's Cube inside jello.
[ Laughter ]
-Hmm.
[ Applause ]
So it's like a pencil sharpener
type of thing.
Where, uh...
Where you put the pencils
or whatever, you put a, uh --
you put a pretzel stick.
[ Laughter ]
In a dude's mouth.
-It is...
-A potato.
-Close.
-Hmm.
-It is a plastic...
cup.
-Mm-hmm.
-It's a plastic cup
filled with beans.
Uh, baked beans.
[ Laughter ]
It's a cup of beans.
-Wait, wait, wait, wait.
[ Chuckles ]
A vibrating jello mold
of Jeff Goldblum.
[ Laughs ]
-In my box was a very thick,
red, gelatinous teddy bear
swaddled in a blanket
with a Binky in its mouth.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Laughs ]
So it's a miniature hot tub.
-Oh, yeah, it's a porcelain --
It's a decent purchase.
It's something you get
in "TV Guide."
You can order it in "TV Guide."
It's, like,
from the Franklin Mint.
Yeah.
-It's a pepperoni pizza.
-[ Laughs ]
Oh, my goodness.
You lie!
-You suck!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my gosh, is that Chewbacca?
[ Laughs ]
You were right!
-Eat this, Jimmy Fallon!
-[ Laughs ]
[ Laughs ]
-I tell the truth.
-Oh!
I don't know what to do.
I don't even know --
That's so bizarre, I didn't know
how to make anything up.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ah! What is that?
-It's weird, right?
-Beans, beans, beans!
Beans!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
-How could I even lie?
After I saw this, how could I
make up a lie about that?
Most insane thing
I've ever seen in my life.